we are coming to you live from rio
grande city texas along the southern
border where texas governor greg abbott
just announced the start of the
construction for his state-funded border
wall here in the state you can hear the
drilling and hammering going on behind
me a historic moment and governor abbott
joins us now governor thank you for
taking time sure great my pleasure
welcome to texas but also as you can
hear and see texas is building the
border wall as we speak right now and
this is unprecedented for a state to
step up and have to secure the
sovereignty of the united states of
america this is the same type of offense
that president trump put up and we're
putting up a very fast pace we want to
build mile after mile after mile to
better secure the united states and the
state of texas why are you doing it
governor because of the tragedy that's
occurred because the byte administration
is not enforcing the immigration laws uh
we have drug cartels we have human
trafficking we have fentanyl
brought across the border there's this
devastating story tragic story about a
woman not too far from where we are
right now she and her daughter lost
their life because a smuggler ran
through a stop sign and t-boned them and
killed them there is devastation every
single day because the bat
administration is not doing its job to
secure our border so texas is stepping
up and doing the federal government's
job
governor we were in mexico this week we
interviewed a gulf cartel smuggler
brazen bold it's clear that they have
never had this kind of control on our
border and it's impacting you in the
state of texas very well and you use a
good word they are they are brazen and
they're brazen because they're not
dealing with president trump now they're
dealing with president biden and what
the cartels know is they have free reign
because the bad administration has open
border policies the cartels are making
money off of every person who comes
across the border so this is the heyday
for the cartels and it's disgusting that
joe biden doesn't realize the
devastation the harm that he's causing
to his fellow americans that's why again
texas is stepping up somebody has to
step up and do the federal government's
job and push back against the obama
administration prevent the chaos uh that
the bad administration is allowing to
happen in texas and in america this wall
historic but governor americans are
really just starting to understand
the operation lone star that you began
in march the impact you've had and it's
really changed the dynamic because
you're starting to prosecute individuals
single males that are trespassing and
some say now that it's gone from a catch
and release under texas it's catching
jail
exactly right and so
the wall is only a part of what we're
doing we have about 10 000 national
guard and department of public safety
officers engaged in this fight
to secure our border and one thing they
do is you see them every single day
arrest people who've come across the
border illegally and they're trespassing
in the state of texas and unlike the
bite administration we're not doing
catch and release we are arresting them
and jailing them for trespass or
vandalism whatever the crime may be
because i declare this a disaster the
penalties for the crime are accelerated
they can spend a half a year to a year
behind bars
governor
talking about fights you may have a
fight from the bite administration from
the doj from civil rights groups filing
lawsuits against you what do you say
for one we believe that we're doing
everything to the letter of the law for
another they can expect a fight from the
state of texas we're going to be suing
them to recoup the money that we're
spending in this we're going to be suing
them for not living up to their duty to
enforce the laws passed by the united
states congress this will be a two-way
fight and i think we're going to win it
if i could just add this real quick i
did that when i was attorney general
when barack obama came up with his own
immigration laws and i won that fight
all the way to the united states supreme
court let's talk a little bit about
waste our own correspondent bill
illusion was asking you about these
panels apparently federal panels sitting
around
rotting
doesn't that seem to be
counterproductive considering you're
going to take this move and move forward
they won't even meet you halfway it
shows that they might the by
administration will do everything they
can to waste taxpayer money
from what i hear those panels they are
not using are already paid for they're
worth billions of dollars we could be
using them here but biden is letting
them go to waste that is an
irresponsible use of taxpayer dollars
governor
back to the smuggling in the cartels
across there
we've spent the entire week with
lieutenant oliveira's and dps i've seen
the guns the ak-47s 50 cals being
apprehended the fentanyl 887 pounds this
year 23 000 pounds of marijuana have you
ever seen
it this bad for one it's never been this
bad there's a reason for it because the
border has never been this open but you
mentioned the guns and it brings me back
to a point that's interesting
and that is some people say oh
americans or texans they don't need guns
the reason why you have a second
amendment right is to defend yourself
the people who live in this area they
have to face the possibility of being
confronted by one of those cartel
members any day they need to have the
firepower to fight back against any
cartel who may threaten them if you got
a message for those cartel
leaders over there they're picking on
the wrong states
i'll tell you i spoke in kenny county to
a rancher lisa connelly she's a fourth
generation rancher she told me the day i
went to interview her governor a migrant
walked right up to her front door
and her husband and son were out on the
ranch working she had to get her guns
she was very worried ultimately nothing
happened they were able to turn the guy
over to border patrol but
it seems to me that they not only are
welcoming your ranch they might even
want to see you prosecute these
trespassers even harder look for
felonies are you just getting started oh
yes so we are prosecuting people for
felonies
there's smugglers people who are
moving drugs there are other crimes that
are taking place that are felonies and
100 percent we are arresting
jailing and prosecuting people for
felonies
we have been doing that all along we are
having to do that
more
increasingly with each passing day
because of the brazen approaches that
the cartels are taking however we wanted
to make it easier to apprehend anybody
coming across the border for trespassing
in the state of texas so that whether it
be for minor crimes or serious crimes
they need to know if they're coming into
texas they're not going to be caught and
released by the administration
they will be arrested and jailed by the
abbott administration
governor rabbit i could talk to you all
day long thank you for having us here
just two seconds last question that is
off camera the agents who work for dps
tell me their morale is improving
because of this what are you hearing so
i hear that from the dps from the
national guard from the workers here
they want a leader who supports what
they're doing they want a leader who's
going to secure the border they want a
leader who has their back all of these
national guard all these law enforcement
officers they know they have a governor
who has their back governor greg abbott
thank you very much historic day here in
texas thank you for joining us jillian
we'll send it back to you